thank you
good evening everybody
welcome
it's great to see you here I can
actually not see you because of the
lights but it's great to have you here
in the room
my name is Chris lubkamin and I have the
great privilege of being your host this
evening but also the head of the
Strategic foresight team within the
Office of the President of the eth in
Zurich
tonight it's rethinking humans and
machines
it's a topic which I'm sure
many of us have thought about either
directly or indirectly
what's our relationship with a machine
what could it be
what will it be
what should it be
in what way will machines in our
interaction with machines change our
perception of our planet of ourselves of
creativity
where will this go
we have a great panel this evening
we are in this Splendid Museum of
Natural History here in Berlin this is
my second time here it's a stunning
stunning exhibition and also within the
Berlin science week
which as most of you many of you know
started in 1917 though it started in
2017.
and we're very proud as the eth to have
been here since its inaugurable year
this week provides a forum for
scientists and science-driven
organizations such as ours to engage
with the public share insights into
current topics to stop discuss Grand
challenges and envision our future
together
please feel free to tweet
to Instagram to share your presence here
things you hear that you like you don't
like not quite sure if Elon is going to
let it get out or not who knows you know
you might have to pay for Tweet now
but please uh use our hashtags we we're
always appreciative of that as is the
balloon science week
also this event part of eth search
rethinking living campaign is something
we've been doing for a couple years is
actually really try to rethinking living
in many different ways from cities down
to molecules what is life actually
and we're all feeling massive change
across just about every aspect of Our
Lives
climate change destruction of
biodiversity the coronavirus pandemic
and technological disruptions which
present threats but more importantly an
opportunity to focus on many of these
Grand challenges
to embrace deeper meaning
and to ReDiscover perhaps
over overlooked aspects of our life
how many of you ever imagined you would
become video Studio experts
I didn't
or to appreciate the act of getting in a
crowded tram again how wonderful was
that you know
rethinking rethinking living convenient
scientists industry experts and
outstanding Global thinkers had various
events around the world
this is also a part of Zurich meets
Berlin
and I encourage you to visit the
exhibition downstairs in the Hall of the
dinosaurs in particular our exhibition
material shapes the ages quite really
quite phenomenal I never would imagine
in my lifetime we would have steel which
could float and you can see some pieces
down there of Steel which can float and
Simone who's our curator is here in the
front row and should be very glad to
answer questions I'm sure and offer you
insights taking you tours until midnight
tonight you know I'm just
uh for those who are online sorry but
you know I guess we have to come here
next year but she's with us and we
really welcome you downstairs
finally our time together this evening
will be around 60 minutes
maybe a little bit longer depending on
how the conversation goes
I'm going to first ask our three
speakers to come up
one at a time we're gonna have a bit of
a dialogue up here and then I'm gonna be
asking for you to share questions or
comments preferably questions and not
those questions which are really
comments but you know what I mean but uh
you know
ask some questions those online you're
welcome to put those into the chat and
the team here will will share them with
us
of all of our folks up front
this interface between the human and the
Machine
is a very interesting one and each one
of our guests have engaged this in a
very different way and I'm personally
really excited to hear from all three of
them
are you ready
yeah thank you come on there you go here
yeah yeah it's the American in the room
what do you think
so let's get started all right
our first guest
it's kind of a local
garage
who's a berlin-based cross-disciplinary
painter interdisciplinary painter and
media artist investigating methods to
redefine one of the earliest forms of
art painting within the current
technology-based area
as she said we were talking ahead of
time essentially using art as a platform
for research which I really like so Leon
welcome come on up give her a hand
foreign
then we have another somewhat local
grew up here doesn't quite live in
Berlin anymore but it's still local
Adina papascu
was a Pioneer in VR AR a philosopher and
a creative technologist she's the
founder of Ayers I'm gonna we're gonna
come back to that in a few minutes
a decentralized environmental data Lake
that aims to simulate the Regeneration
solutions for our planet open sourced
and distributed which I really I'm
really looking forward to hearing more
about is her focus on indigenous
learning and what we can be taking from
capturing that Knowledge from indigenous
peoples
so Adina come on up welcome let's give
her away
[Applause]
and last but not least
our homegrown
eth team my numbers last but not least
we have Alexander Ilitch he's the
executive director and co-founder of the
eth AI Center he's a Swiss German deep
Tech entrepreneur researcher and
investor he co-founded the computer
vision startup dakuda which was acquired
by augmented reality Pioneer magic leap
in 2017 and is really doing an awful lot
with us helping us to see where AI can
help us move into the future across all
sorts of different domains so I'm really
looking forward to hearing his views on
this Alex come on up
foreign
so with that we're gonna get started
yeah
hi hello you're right here I got you
right here I got some notes Here For You
um you have this interface between
humans
and you said painting
and this Medium as we were talking
earlier is this meeting which is so
unpredictable
and how to use a machine
to
utilize
this unpredictability in a way
where did that come where did that come
from where did that in your life where
did that where did that germ of the idea
come from
and
um
I'm trained in painting and print
was always fascinating about the
craftsmanship of the painting the
painting is a process
and less about the idea of the finished
image
and working as an artist in our time I
realized I do spend huge amount of my
time in front of computers I'm looking
at
pixels in different kind of forms
but those images are not reflecting
representing the complex process that
has with interaction of materials that
are actually inherent into the
craftsmanship and the work that involved
in painting
and that kind of brought me into the
point of understanding that the digital
world cannot give me
the tools that I need and I'm interested
in however the work with computational
power and the ability of
generating of information translation of
information transformation of
information saving variation
Etc was an element that was really
fascinating interested of continue and
explore and that brought me into the
understanding or the wish to work with
robotics
and this was kind of Joint Forces I've
spent some times in the United States in
MIT working with artists in New York and
slowly in MIT actually my professor
Oliver doyson from the University of
constance the pioneering project of the
edavit painting robot and I can join
forces with them since 2016.
and in the work with um the group of
Professor doyson's computer
um graphic so they are doing actually
with pixel representation
I come to the realization of the
importance of the definition of what it
means to have a single brush stroke what
how can we change the goal from a
deterministic processes of trying to
achieve a certain let's say image and
actually look into the interaction
elements of the decision making of eye
hand connection and the branching
Endless Possibilities that happen with
the interaction with biological chemical
reactions physical reaction of materials
so it's almost like two nights ago the
privilege of hosting a conversation with
Ed catmull who the founder of Pixar and
at the end the the the product was the
image
but yours the the process is
the product or am I wrong
I think the word product is something
that I'm not very comfortable Fair okay
because I think this is as well
something that is inherent to how we
think in our society today in our the
need of creating products to deliver a
Finnish object and are more interesting
in the matter of thought and you kind of
mentioned before about the Dealer's
practice about the indigenous knowledge
and something that is interesting in
indigenous knowledge in that
understanding is working as groups is
having rituals is having a different set
of Minds that bring us to the creation
if it will be artifacts or would it be
um food or clothes or
that has a very different approach and
this is what are more interesting and
mindset that art creation is in a craft
manner in a temporal element
is more interesting to me than creating
product that one can then trade in the
market okay that's fantastic now you
have we also have a
a film a little video clip yes of a work
that I've done together with University
of consensus
um two years ago dealing with the
definition of what is a brush Strokes
can a machine recognize a brush Strokes
can a machine repeat it and you can have
perfect great
[Music]
foreign
ly beautiful
and that could be really mean and just
say well so just a bunch of brush
Strokes
yeah I have to say that my practice
through working with computer
informatics and Robotics I moved from
making paintings to trying to understand
what is a brass choice
but that goes into you know it has a big
philosophical question but it's as well
deeply
like it's the most
way like the most basic way of human
communication is making a line and it
has in that the information of a human
gesture and I specifically focused using
rice paper and ink so this is of course
strongly references to the calligraphic
tradition in the Far East which I
studied but very little so I'm as well
trying to even respect respectful to
this culture
um but I found it so interesting the
level that you have so many hairs in the
brush and everything that you do it's
recording and you cannot undo it there
is no undo button you cannot erase it
no but even if to differentiate from oil
paints acrylic painting let's say you
cannot over paint it you cannot erase it
the paper is very thin and it takes
everything in the it's saturated with
water and then the second stroke already
will behave very differently than the
first one so that's already different
kind of level of changes and in this
exhibition it started from one bra
Strokes that I did and then the machine
was trying to repeat it but it never
managed to and that create this endless
like it was a hundred more roll of paint
of paper that it was just keep in this
Loop exactly trying and trying and that
brings a lot of question of showing the
limitation of computational vision to
see how a brush Strokes look like how
One Translate
uh image that comes as pixels into a
gestural element embodied element as a
stroke itself and so was was I'm trying
to think of the magic within it was
something the algorithmic magic so it
was learning because we saw some of the
tracing
was it it was learning as it was going
or I'm trying to think was there an AI
was there AI within that as no or no not
in that project but right now I'm
working inside with the my project at
the at the collage room and part with
um
The Institute of neuroinformatics
on using real life like real-time Loop
that it actually can see how what it's
doing it's not only to know what it's
doing but it's to learn how materials
behave and according to that to learn
what kind of a gesture was being made
and how to achieve it again it's
something that if I will ask even you to
do it you think a brushstroke is very
easy I can assure you by 100 you will
never manage to repeat the same Strokes
that you did you've yeah
you've seen my artwork so I guess okay
yeah thank you
yes okay like a lot of people think just
a stroke it's such a simple thing but
there is a lot of knowledge that one
need to take into consideration that
happened in our hand tips it's true
because of the the humidity of the paper
that the moment how much water is it's
so so variable this was really quite
incredible with that it's really cool so
with that I'm going to move over to
Adina this is a fantastic start
um Adina yes
humans and machines you have a history
we all have a history
um and you've you've worked in AR VR and
there's a sort of a vector which has
brought you to where you are now with
this massive data Lake which focus on so
share with us just a a short version of
my life yeah you know maybe you know the
cliff notes version if you know what
that means yeah
um yeah I got I got really fascinated
with uh with VR air in around 2013. I
think oh my
I'm the only one who didn't turn off her
phone
um
exactly and and I wrote uh three virtual
reality film scripts uh in a time where
actually nobody really knew what that
was and um I think the entertainment
industry was filled with directors who
wanted to control the gays
and so they felt very uncomfortable with
a medium in which they had to all think
of how to actually create something in
real time where you actually don't have
control over over the viewer on how he
behaves in that that environment
and uh I think out of lack of lack of
competition in that early stage I got I
got um invited to LA and I started
working with with really uh wonderful
people on doing r d and vrar
um I think what what really bothered me
very soon is that of course you always
have a very I mean I'm a philosopher so
I always have an idealist realized
version of of the world and uh when and
my first interest was to actually
visualize music in VR
and and to use musical stems connect
them with a color and then you know
basically give people like a cinestatic
experience and allow them to interact
with music but then the industry went
straight to Violent gains and porn and
it went very far away from what I was
envisioning and then I started becoming
really worried about the way how we
handle data in inside of that
environment if because if people are
already worried about Cambridge
analytica and what happened there with
voter influencing what is going to
happen in a fully controlled environment
that is fully controlled by a company
and in which in which
um the the environment is so realistic
and I know that everybody who maybe
tried VR knows that if you try to walk
over an abyss
you know you're in an office space but
you cannot take that step because your
brain is is is so good and powerful yeah
so I got really worried about the level
of manipulation in in those tools and I
hope I turned that was actually the
first time I started thinking about open
source tools and about
um blockchain back then in 2017 16
trying to understand how can we actually
give create
some kind of
um
self-serving identity where people can
control their own data or can actually
say okay this is the part of data I'm
I'm giving to the system and this one I
want to take a keep private and to
create some kind of co-ownership and
that led me to um over over many
obstacles I started actually working
with an NGO I I I learned a lot about
NGO work
um and they're the same it's always like
the puppet data now it always shows up
it was always the same problem right so
I started talking to to scientists who
are doing um remote sensing and we all
know that you know most satellite data
is open and is is readily available you
can use computer vision algorithm to
detect um you know um
um foreign
is to have in situ data
so they're the same thing most in situ
data and most relevant on the ground
data that gives us insight about
irregularities but also a lot of a lot
of
[Music]
um
information that just cannot be observed
from space you know like you cannot
really do a good carbon carbon
um
storage
um estimation from space right you need
on the ground data and there I
encountered the same thing as soon as
you basically have industry somehow
attached to the groups on the ground
ground funding the groups on the ground
those data sets were closed again
and uh so everywhere I went I realized
okay there's a relationship between
funding
and and
um the data that humans and on the
ground are producing and this led me
slowly slowly and more and more to
actually I feel that Earth has been
really more a philosophical inquiry for
a very long time because it's been such
a long time in the in the making
But ultimately what we're trying to do
is we're trying to um we're on we're not
trying we're actually doing it right now
we're basically creating a data
repository in which people are
incentivized to publish their AI models
on on impact evaluation make them
peer-to-peer reviewable and and to and
they're incentivized to also standardize
and polish their data sets and to use
web3 tools like like um decentralized
storage to allow people to compute over
each data set and to update them and
that would really allow a collaboration
where we could generate larger and
larger data
from what's going on on the ground and
from satellite data that would give us a
much broader spectrum of understanding
yeah I'll stop right here so I think you
also have a you also have a little film
clip which we could take oh yeah which
is yes where did you jump in the gun
there guys there you go well that's good
actually it's very slow in the beginning
it's this is a film we did a year ago
um
we used we used you know landsat landsat
um satellite data and then I spent a lot
of time in Brazil I started honing into
indigenous territories because I started
you know looking at at carbon credits at
ESG credits at all these upcoming
incentives that we have in the industry
to to offset
um emissions
and I was wondering you know the more I
was speaking to communities on the
ground it became very clear that often
indigenous communities who are sitting
on the healthiest land and have
protected the land for Generations not
really have access to the funds from
carbon credits instead then white guys
in Michigan who own land in Panama and
plant eucalyptus trees refined into
their land with carbon credits so
um I was trying to understand how can we
actually create something that's
transparent and trustable
and allows us to get a good estimate of
what is actually going on on the ground
because I think one of the biggest
thresholds that we have right now in the
ESG and carbon credit conversation is
um that we actually do not know what
impact is
we assume impact and then we fund it
so what we're trying to do is to
retroactively basically first create a
model on what could be the best form of
regeneration
establish impact evaluators and then
drive funding towards it yeah that's
great I mean because it seems like
there's a lot of folks who are trying to
look at that exactly trying to
understand what's what's the
the actual carbon sinking if you just
only look at Carbon but it's also
biodiversity and the whole geochemical
flows all of the different planetary
boundaries if you will on a place and
mapping them layering them in which
would be really fantastic so we can see
where the Delta needs to go exactly
that's good now how many people are
participating in this now I mean they're
feeding into this we're we're very small
team we're still only six people yeah uh
we're working on the MVP minimal viable
product yeah but um Most Valuable Player
most and most viable no no no
um but um because we're a network and
because we are um we're blockchain based
we really see that not so much we don't
see ourselves as a company we're really
a network that is incentivizing through
a token economy participation through
bounties um and and really like
large-scale peer review and this is also
really important to me because I think
that maybe the the next Innovation comes
from like a team of kids in India yeah
and and we need to be more inclusive and
and actually allowing everybody to have
access to those
um to this data that's great thank you
very much for that okay and this is the
perfect segue to Alex so Alex
access
and tell us a little bit about how you
ended up becoming the
I call it the lightning rod for AI at
the eth with the AI Center and what
you're trying to achieve there
so I spent some time as an entrepreneur
building a computer vision startup right
in the transition from using a lot of
classical programming classical math
geometry and then transitioning more
towards learning based models what it
means that you know we moved somehow
from programming computers with Punch
Cards lines of codes and and uh a very
classical math models too now teaching
machines with data what we want to
achieve and I think that's something
where I believe as humans we're very
very good at creating tools
and using tools also to propel us
forward and for me AI is one of the
tools that is significant in the next
next 10 years and I also realized that
people are afraid because every new
change people are resistant and try to
understand it which is quite normal and
the speed that has been in this field
because before we had you know big data
and then suddenly we had the ability to
do something with it we had the compute
we had the algorithm we had a lot of
progress in that part that seemed to be
very very fast
and what I think like many people still
have the idea that
which I would say is now a little bit
outdated that you're afraid that somehow
an AI takes over and replaces us I think
the the problem in the next 10 20 years
is not that I think the next 10 20 years
is how can we use AI uh meaning
leveraging the data leveraging this as a
tool to be more effective of what we
want to accomplish discover new drugs
fight climate change in increased
biodiversity and things like this right
so we need to learn how to use this tool
make this accessible to everyone it has
also to do a lot with data and
potential access to data and risk so I
think this is an amazing example here
and yeah one of my functions where I
look what is success look like is how
can we enable especially more young
talents to make a big impact on this
um because I think like career choices
especially in difficult Economic Times
um is very important that a large
proportion of people considers building
their own company because if you look at
the big companies that are today fueled
by data
they are now old dinosaurs to make a
reference to to downstairs right so they
are at the risk of going extinct and I
think this is also on the one hand side
very beautiful that there's a cycle in a
new opportunity so we always get chances
to to start again and bring fresh ideas
in and I think we're in one of these
phases
um and if bigger companies you know have
the same problems like everyone else
then we need younger and more more fast
startups and entrepreneurs coming up and
yeah so this is a little bit the mission
I believe that still there will be a lot
going on in AI foundations so at eth
we're across departmental Center so
across all the 16 departments from
architecture social sciences computer
science electric engineering so the
whole span and in many of them their new
AI foundations being developed
so which make it more effective that
systems can learn from less data and
generalize better and if we're very good
at bringing this faster to where it's
needed most the different application
areas then I think we can accelerate
progress and really make a substantial
advances in a number of fields so this
is a little bit positive
Technology's point of view but I truly
believe that this is something where we
are right now at this point and we can
come back maybe to this later I think
like we should be just careful that
we're not
um
too skeptical about certain aspects of
it but there are other areas where I
feel we should be more skeptical we can
can dive more more deeply in this oh I
love how you just dangled that out there
yeah say okay we can come back to it
let's do it right now let's go ahead
you've got the stage
keep going yeah if if we want to jump in
a little bit I think like um
so what are the things that we should be
um less skeptical of I think like it's
it not the topic that machines make
decisions for us
right so it's it's still feeding us with
um opportunities of uh you know this
like it condenses a lot of data so we
are able it gives us new superpowers
we're able to deal with a lot more data
that we couldn't process ourselves so I
think machines are extremely good in
doing boring repetitive and dangerous
tasks which we want to get rid of right
um and so I I would say it actually
helps us to amplify more of what humans
are good at and what makes also fun uh
for us the thing where I um which is a
little bit underestimate is what
substantial power shift this requires on
many many parts where we need to break
up many silos and uh my concern is that
you know we missed the last maybe 10
years where big database companies were
built and now we take all our concerns
and anger out on the young startups that
are coming up
so so this is something where I would
say
um we should rethink uh the the power
structures that are there today and what
can we do to shift that I saw both of
your heads dot bobbing up and down on
that one and what what were you bobbing
your head at when you were when he was
saying the power shifts and the data and
looking forward
[Music]
points
kind of only stop when you start with a
positive element and you said what
technology is allowing us and I wonder
when you say it give who is we who is
who is us who is this people that you
talk about because I think it's
um excluding like from our perspective
a lot of people that don't have this
access and don't have this knowledge and
this has come with the most economical
access just for for the machines itself
for the technological like
platforms itself and on the other part
that you talked about you know the anger
that we have to the concentration of
data that have by the big companies and
how it's being targeted into the young
startups today
it made me be thinking
if it's about the systems themselves or
like let's say like the the companies
themselves or would it be more accurate
I think and to stop and think about our
mindset and in that case I will talk
about more the capitalist system and we
cannot separate one from the other when
you talk about the use of AI
as a new opportunity without talking
about the capital system that it's kind
of thriving it so there is a good
relationship happening between the two
and how that can be changed because we
are right now politically wise in a
shifting right a bit scary to my opinion
and then the tools of AI in those times
is
for me more of a danger than opportunity
like I agree with you about all the
great things that it can actually enable
us but it feels to me like it yeah but
that's yeah I I would actually divert
this over to Adina because I mean you
did this kind of move right now where
basically you're taking things making
them more open I think this is a very
important tool that we we can can use so
I I don't know you have probably said in
a lot of situations where before it was
very strong structures which are now
breaking up absolutely um foreign
yes I think this is exactly like AI is a
great tool let's not underestimate that
it's a really great tool and humans have
always created great tools that help
them along but this is really also what
it is and we need to a demystify it
um and secondly of course of course as
you said we actually and especially in
Europe we kind of missed that boat in
the last 10 to 15 years where Silicon
Valley companies created this incredible
um
data Hoover like you know like like
collection of data that would allow them
to basically move fast with with
artificial intelligence and we cannot
disconnect AI from the business models
in fact All Digital startups have only
one business model and that's basically
we're going to sell our data analysis
from Bloomberg to the younger startups
there is no other business model so the
problems and today yeah yeah so actually
the business models are the problem and
not AI so the way we monetize and we
capitalize on something that actually
should be shared knowledge because a
good AI algorithm is comprised of so
much data from so many people
so if we take that and we pretend that
there was no participation and no
relationship between those we took the
data from and the model
then we really have to rethink the way
we do business and that's actually why I
moved to blockchain because until today
I'm actually convinced that there's no
way
to build what we're building
and to have a revenue which we need
and opening up fully all the data so the
way we chose to do it is through through
a token economy
I'm actually quite fascinated we started
off with humans humans and machines
we've landed on our
so socioeconomic system
it all goes back to that well but shows
you know what some of the drivers are
the drivers for Change and as you've
pointed out at the moment we're in this
precarious moment in history
and with also with the tools which we
have at our fingertips or or not as you
also say if you don't but I would like
to come back to something you say which
I'm not sort of like machines making
decisions for us we shouldn't be worried
about that
would you what what do you two think
about this Alex's he's he's convinced
what about you is this something
convinced
I missed that convinced of a machine
that should you agree with that we
shouldn't be we shouldn't worry about
machines making decisions for us we're
talking about humans and machines got it
do you agree
I have a bit of a sorry who's uh either
one of you it's a bit out of context
it's coming you know pray Alex that way
yeah
that's true
um
but
first of all we'd like to break it down
on me to ask what it means to make
decisions because making decisions
there's the big one that you aware of
the decision that you're making and I'm
sorry I'm taking it back into painting
but I am a pain that's what I actually
wanted to go is because this machine is
deciding what it's going to do but there
is a lot of decision that happening in
in a smaller scale that this is what I'm
talking about the mindset of where we
are in a situation and it's a kind of to
differentiate automaticized like
processes into an Adaptive One
and I don't believe right now and I
think this is something that right now
the AI Center is dealing with a lot with
I know if adaptive is the right word but
you have with
um
like the idea of having machines being
more open to community to collaborate
with human and for that you need a level
of adaptation that means to open up the
decision that you can make to a much
larger and in a way as well unexpected
outcomes and of course I'm coming from
the Arts where it's a in a way a safe
environment for playfulness you can try
out stuff and if something doesn't work
out no harm happening but I'm always
going back into it because it's like a
really beautiful
[Music]
um
series of lecture by Australia Franklin
the real world of technology from things
to the late 80s or 90s
ancient history exactly ancient history
but she created kind of two definitions
of Technology one she called
prescriptive technology and the other
ones you called holistic technology and
I always going back into it because I
like
how she differentiated the two into one
that means following orders and I will
make a jump here into how it's operated
music for example that you have
orchestra musician that they need to
follow the notation in order to operate
and this is almost like was a military
structure but then there is the holistic
technology it means reaction and
adaptation to a current situation and
this is will be more as
jazz in a way
improvisation doesn't happen
but it's about the level of being alert
to everything that's happening around
you and to be able to respond and in
that moment of response it's not only
about oh what will sound nice there is
so many elements that we are not even
aware that could be about the level of
what they ate yesterday and how I feel
right now if I slept good or I don't
know a dream I had or my relationship
with my mother it could be a lot of
things
but this is the human factor that for me
is crucial in the decision making and
when we're going into
a big data situation to automatization
we removing this element and I see it
more and more in Labs that are selling
right now to create medicine medication
like the lab situation of
playing around with materials and making
decisions almost disappeared because we
relying so much about the simulation
that prediction that AI will give us and
me as a person who is interested in the
craft and the importance of craft
however to see how that can be
integrated in the time of machinis
for me the interesting part to use the
machine as an extension for the decision
making that we have but not something to
rely on for decision making
carrying on that
wisdom
humans have wisdom or some do or maybe
not but in all seriousness
humans have wisdom which we either earn
or it's a collective indigenous people
have a oral history of observational
science if you will
and wisdom which can be passed
how does this what's that relationship
between wisdom and the Machine
in fact I'm thinking there's two words
humans and machines the wisdom that
takes that's a stroke or the wisdom of
the indigenous peoples or making
judicial decisions in
from an algorithm where's the wisdom
where is it going to sit how are we
going to hold it
who wants who wants to go for that one
Alec
so yeah you said like uh uh um one thing
that he said the wisdom and making
decisions like uh um
I think that will will stay with with
people with humans
um for a long time so that's one of the
problems that I would not put for the
next 10 or 20 years
um
and I think what what's very important
is just the question is like okay if now
a lot of maybe repetitive tasks before
for instance drug Discovery I I needed a
lot of experiment before I can move
forward now I can reduce it from this
universe of experience to a smaller set
that I can advance faster right so this
would be another part so I don't think
it replaces the craft the craftsmanship
and also the wisdom in part but it helps
us to move faster and this is kind of
like what I what I see and
um
one example I don't know like how many
the audience tried you know this um text
to to image generation so so did anyone
tried it in the audience yeah
half of the people
um did any one of you notice how hard it
is when you have a specific goal in mind
to achieve it anyone
yeah so so the problem is with this that
um you realize suddenly now that if you
have a model that is trained on on a
specific data set it has learned
something it has also learned specific
ways of expressing something which might
not be your own right so there's not a
very high level of personalization it's
sometimes very hard to get exactly what
you want and I think this is something
which I would like to see in the next 10
years that the systems become a more a
lot more attuned to our way of thinking
so they learn with each interaction how
we express ourselves what we want to do
to help us in in the process and not the
other way around so this is one of the
reasons why I'm not using like voice
assistance like Siri because I feel like
I need to learn too much to change the
way like in to pro so for me it's just
like a variable programming right so
there's no no uh yeah
like what
how do you know what comes first to be
the chicken or the egg because when
there is a standardization in a global
way of certain kind of aesthetical
manner of expression you will try to
achieve if you're just a teenager want
to put something in social media you
want to have something that looks like
what everybody else already done so
this is actually something that
automatically reduce the ability of
actually self-expression because
of the system itself so this is what I'm
saying like you know so about the design
of the systems itself what influence
what and where
so I I would say it gives us for
instance a power of recombination of
existing things yeah and there it it
speeds up some things but you cannot
achieve a full end-to-end part what you
want it accelerates a few things I mean
what would be what is an interesting
question is then how do you break with
those those parts I think this is a big
topic um in in your work um as well
um I think it's great like for instance
if I'm creating now figures for
PowerPoint
it's not important that it looks super
original I just want to express a
certain part that it matches with what I
have maybe on the text for this purpose
it's fine right but if you want to
create something truly new then it's
maybe something that you need different
tools you need to enhance it and and so
on but I think one uh one way that it um
increases is that we are able to express
ourselves better with images
so I think that would be in the future
something that we say when we do
brainstorming in the future we can
easily use that because we can also
implicitly communicate for instance a
mood that we wanted to transport which
is very hard if I just you know I'm not
an artist so for me it's very hard to
draw it you could maybe draw it right
but this would give me the power for
instance to express a concept easier
than uh than spending a long time
um yeah but this is just about
Expressions more about matters of
communication this is through imagery so
it's a different way it's more about
codification of of a new language it is
not based on letters but it's actually
based on images
so I think it's a different balance
about the combination of different
images together that goes into this
codification yeah
and what I'm what I'm saying in this
this process is like just that today if
you use any of the systems today the
most of the time built the way that if
you use them more often they don't learn
to what you do it's more the opposite
right so we need to learn how Theory
works right and not the other way around
in the same way that um which is coming
to the business models I mean yes we get
personal recommendations but the
Personnel is related it's just a
economical function of what we're most
likely to buy it's not really what I
personally want so I want this ability
that we can express what problems do we
want solved and that the interactions so
maximizing the bandwidth from us that
you don't need to be a programmer
anymore to express yourself towards
getting something with a machine so this
would be kind of like a a a good state
to be in in the next next 10 years
go ahead Adina and then we're gonna I
would like to contribute to this for a
second though because I I do I I do um
recognize liat's point and I think the
problem here is containers right we live
in a containered society right a
Facebook Instagram Tick Tock has
basically created a way for us to be
creative within a container that has
been set for has set the framework of
how we actually express ourselves
and I'm a big fan of people like
Lawrence Lasik who created the Creative
Commons license and I really again think
the problem here is not in technology
but everything around it
um I with Earth I'm a True Believer in
radical collaboration and collective
intelligence and I really believe that
if you give people the tools they will
be so creative with them but if you
underestimate people and you try to play
create playful containers and plug and
play systems for them because you
already assume that they're not as smart
as the scientists and therefore you
basically already container them in the
way that they can express themselves
then you create a Brave New World so
really this is and sorry I just um and I
think it's I'm always surprised actually
how many people code python like I'm
sitting in some kind of like hostel in
Brazil and there's this guy who's like
18 years old and he's like oh I'm using
python to actually look at cloudforce in
the Amazon and how they're changing and
I'm I'm so impressed with every time I
speak with like even like 18 year olds
or 12 year olds who are actually coding
and they say that the next Frontier of
illiteracy is not knowing how to read a
book but not knowing how to read code
and to me it really comes down to
education everybody should send their
children to computer chaos club with
five years old they should learn to code
in order to not be containered by the
future AI tools that are basically then
controlled by companies who are putting
those containers out limiting expression
a great plea for education education
education we like that absolutely thank
you questions this is a chance for I
either those online or for you to share
a question with us here's one there's
one in the back we have microphones we
have we have probably one or two
no we need a microphones so those online
can hear it too the microphone's right
in front of you you turn around
thank you hi thank you very much for
giving me the opportunity to ask a
question I actually have several
questions but you get one because you
just yeah because you just mentioned the
creative license
thing actually that's my most pressing
question because what about ownership
like when you use AI you you're not
actually it's not your creativity it's
the creativity of all the data that you
give to the to the machine and
especially in arts and now my other
questions kind of connected to this all
right I know I'm not allowed to ask okay
so but it's a connector a good question
that's a good question let's stay with
that one let's stay with that one so
yeah
what about that it's a good question
any of you yeah yeah
this question always is the first
question to come in everything
so we're gonna put we're gonna take the
mic back and um
I always like I'm just really fascinated
about the fact that we are really
obsessed with knowing the ownership like
you know to attribute to someone and I'm
kind of going back into this
understanding of knowledge of community
of trying to say what about the fact
that it's an oh like it's owned by a
community that create a certain work
as a way of thinking about it and going
back as well to the discussion I had we
had here just right now
I think a lot of it is not only about
who is the one to get the the license or
the title or the the autogram on it
it is where the question of control how
much did I control and influence what
happened here and how much was being
happened to me and I just reacted so
there is a lot that I would put the
power in the vision that has a lot to do
with the philosophy behind it the
decision making and The Envision of
where we're going if it's in artwork if
it's in um
yeah creating of
new businesses companies I would meet
kind of the same
other comments or you want to make
comments or no
I I do agree with you though because I
think that if we have tools like in the
music industry for example tools being
fed to musicians in which they're
collaborating then the question is very
valid you know who ultimately owns the
IP right on that collaboration between
human and machine right and and often we
don't read the fine print
um and and I do I do believe actually
that we again we need new structures for
that we need to understand you know like
if if I use a certain tool I have also
co-created that tool because I've also
furthered that tool so how do I get
co-ownership but this is where I always
go back to blockchain and IP on on chain
that's the that's will be always my
answer great thank you any other other
questions
okay one up here one there's two up here
three one two three
uh we'll start start with the middle
then we'll go here and then go here okay
yes you with the white black shirt and
then
go right there go ahead thank you very
much so for this very interesting panel
and I also had the possibility to hear
the other panel on ethical AI uh at
lunch time so I think it connects very
nicely
um so I'm gonna start and and ask a
related question namely you know we've
heard many things about what we can and
cannot shoot or should not do with AI
but in the end what you can and cannot
do is based on what is the legal
framework right so what does the
regulator allow you to do and the
regulator is always behind because the
legislative process takes many many
years and what we are doing at the
moment in Europe is in the EU I should
say we are creating the legal framework
for the next decade with the data
governance Act and the AI act and so my
question would be from your perspective
is this going in the right direction
because we need to find the balance
between protecting civil rights privacy
and so on and also enabling Innovation
so it's question two whoever feels they
want to ask so we're back to
socioeconomic geopolitics yeah so so
maybe I can say a few things on this so
um
so so there no one knows what's right or
wrong we would only know retrospectively
right so 10 years in maybe we can answer
what this uh if this was good or not
um what we're trying for instance in in
Zurich we're very closely working with
the local government with the with the
Canton we have created a Sandbox where
basically just all of the companies and
startups can come with questions on how
do they do things today what's allowed
how should they do it because in general
I made the observation that companies
here care quite a lot about data in
protecting people and I think it should
not be forgotten that we
um set the right incentive that the good
Solutions are getting you know a
stronger boost so um uh we take a little
bit more of a bottom-up approach right
so we look at what are case is there how
can we strengthen those that that are
there and then maybe they're parts that
need to be regulated get smaller and
smaller because if people are doing a
good job you know that are embodying
maybe the value system also more
strongly that's present in Europe then
the space that we actually need to
regulate becomes much smaller than if we
say let's regulate everything right so
this might be one approach I don't know
which one is better to take on
everything holistically at once or to
try this bottom up we tried at the
moment with the bottom-up way and we'll
see um what what comes out better
it's a tough question to answer
very tough because we're in a global
competitive Marketplace and this is our
reality
and it's a it's a very legitimate
question and I don't think we can answer
that right now but it's a good one over
a glass of wine we have another question
right here all right this gentleman
right here in the sweater right Nina
right there right there there you go and
then we'll come over to you and then
there's one in the back yep
so um my question is
um
about the flash stroke for example
I think the the the machines the
computer the AI will be at some point it
will be able to make the brush stroke
and to paint because like if it's more
computational power and more sensorics
and
um also there's the problem with the
sense of time and feelings and intuition
but it could uh theoretically learn how
that goes and also it could learn about
society and could
um and to reflect on society and things
like that so uh theoretically the AI
could at some point make better art as a
human artists
um would that be a problem it's just
that can I say something to that because
I sure go for it this is so funny
because I've heard this this comment
before and I always want I always think
that humans make art for humans like if
a machine was to start enjoying its own
art maybe it would compose music on
Wi-Fi and we would never know about it
you know like the whole point of AI is
to actually give us a tool to express
ourselves and there is no good or better
because it is the human that will always
feel the satisfaction from art or not if
AI decides to generate its own
intelligence we will most likely it will
do it most likely on a level and
frequency that we have zero access to so
it's not even relevant for us
so maybe if I can add one perspective to
that because what is very nice that you
said like oh at some point this will be
better than us and I think this is a
narrative that is very sticky with AI
has been at the early beginning the
touring test beating people at chess at
go and so on I think this is a point
where I would actually start changing
the narrative because it changes how we
think so we should not think of oh when
is it possible to replace this what we
can do and love right because if this is
our thinking that AI will replace the
stuff that we do and love then we're in
trouble because it only means like we're
there's fear and then with fear you know
you can either run away or you know you
don't move at all right and I think what
would be more useful is the question
what can we do with AI that we could not
do before
because if you look back in the history
there has always been things that we can
do now you know thanks to electricity to
computers and so on so these are at the
end of the day the things that matter
for history so we should focus on you
know writing this chapter of history
proactively and and I think this would
be nice also to see that reflected in
public dialogue and in the press in the
media and so on it's a difficult
question but um I really like like this
one also good for a glass of wine
there's a great article by budrier the
philosopher where he describes how he
went into a Japanese elevator and he
heard music for the first time and he
felt that he heard
um Beethoven in five dimensions and it
was so perfect but he didn't feel
anything
because because the Perfection of it uh
the the generated music still didn't
resonate with him
so maybe that we stated well stated
there's another question here then
there's another in the middle this
gentleman okay well you'll get next and
hey thank you so much
um I have one question and um it's about
bias
um I mean working with neural networks
we discovered that some models have a
certain bias and instead of trying to
eliminate it is there a way to use it in
a positive way as in like a guidance
guidance
um for a positive outcome yeah that's
basically the question
yeah so I think one thing which is
important so bias is an important topic
right because we know that data doesn't
represent the world
yeah so this example maybe you have seen
this uh at some point if you ask if you
train a model for what color does the
banana have it says green right because
yellow is normal so this is encoded that
the color that you can find is green not
not yellow because this is normal so
Norms are encoded and things there so
data is biased labeling is biased if
it's done especially also by people with
different backgrounds and so on models
are biased and then the other problem is
as well if you're using a system and the
user interface is created in a way that
suggests something very strongly it can
create a feedback loop that makes it
even worse so that's bad side because if
you run with data anything bad and data
gets Amplified so this is a typical
failure model for companies that have a
very bad process they say oh my God our
hiring process is just hiring men but
let's use AI to fix it
yeah so guess what it makes the problem
way worse right so AI is a force
multiplier because you know this is what
you you put in
um but the good news is um there we have
now the tools so we have now the tools
to synthetically generate data of
underrepresented cases that we didn't
have before so there's no excuse that we
don't have data for our case we have
tools to to look into the stability of
network so we can even debug the network
not just the data to find out where
their problems
um if everyone is using that yet I would
say there's still a lot to catch up but
uh people realize that building a good
AI system is more engineering than uh
just a black box that I think changed um
but if you use the tools you're very
well will quickly discover where do you
have the weaknesses
do you guys want to add anything
open open AI open software it's a very
important you need to know the footnotes
that went into the book that has been
written if you close off the footnotes
then you will never know the biased
that's a great metaphor I like that well
done there's a question right up here is
there anyone who else has a question in
the room
this one and all right sorry I think I
took your place
uh my name is Christopher Taylor I'm a
PM in uh predictive
predictive Behavior Analysis and
emotional AI so this is actually a
question that was brought on by Alex's
comment uh but it is a question for
everyone on the panel uh you said that
AI will give us superpowers
um but this has been the promise of
technology for it's forever as long as I
can remember and the world isn't in a
really great place right now like I
don't feel that people are particularly
happy so why is the future of AI
different
huh
I I like this question actually a lot
I think um
that's a really good question
all the promise there's always a
technology promise and and the promise
of positive change
sorry go ahead and then all right I
think really that this is what we have
to take out to me this is really um PR I
I don't think that AI is going to make
the world a better place humans are
going to make a world a better place
it's a tool you know and it depends on
what we do with that tool it's not the
AI is 100 not a promise it's just a
great tool to basically seep through
huge data sets and to do tedious work
it's um I think demystification is very
important
um but it's a great tool but it's a tool
yeah I agree with you on that I think
there's something that you can say as
you said the promise of technology is
something that engrave in human history
from technology starts and it will be
from the first technological tools we
use to work out the land to create
Agriculture and agriculture is something
that people will say the beginning of
the problem for our planet today
on the other hand starvation and so so I
think it's always the question
as Adina said here it's a tool and it's
always reflect on us and us as a society
and are we willing to do something
better with that I do things though that
yes AI gave
um the centralization of data into the
position that it's we are in a dangerous
place right now because the
how exponential the technology makes
power I think distribution in the wrong
way but again it's it's on us it's not
on the technology at all
it's a great question we're going to
take one more question right here no I
think right here and then the front one
very patient up here it's gonna be our
last question
before I come back to the panel for a
question the wrap up
and then we're gonna go downstairs have
a glass of water thank you
um yeah I would like to question the the
loss of creativity that comes from these
tools because you mentioned earlier that
um you now have the possibility to just
write any text and get an image out of
it and I think you referred to Dolly
from openai and there's gpt3 that
generating text from creativity from
text in in the past and there's even the
music industry who's warning for music
from AI so
um
uh yeah mentioned in the beginning that
the process of doing the brush stroke
um is like the creative way that cannot
be reproduced by AI so is there the
possibility to lose this creative way
when all of humanity starts to use the
tools that will take the the creativity
creative
from the humanity yeah
so what was the question exactly sorry
losing creativity okay
well I feel that I already said
something towards that with the
containers you know like you know like
if you basically create those containers
Plug and Play containers that allow
people to use them for their creativity
you limit creativity
and um that's where I always go back to
just give people the tools and allow
them to create and create a new
licensing system I want to as well add
to this because this is actually what
brought me to become this new
constellation of artistic research in
that understanding and to move Hands-On
on the technology I'm coming from
painting and in the Art Academy you're
never being taught about how to paint
and when I start working with robotics
of course the painting department at the
Art Academy of Leipzig just throw me out
of the Departments that go into the
media art this is not painting anymore
um instead of like trying to understand
that this is a reaction in order to say
I want to have my hands on a technology
so I can design it for my creative needs
because I didn't like the fact that
as Alex here said that we're using
imagery today more than ever for
communication
on top of it there is a global market
and every art student feels in order to
be up in the painting department let's
say and to know I need to be up in
what's going on in the world to be up to
date and create the best things
I need to consume as much as I can from
this imagery how do I consume this
through my phones most art students are
really poor so they have usually shitty
fonts and they have really
representation of imagery that they try
to somehow then represent or be
influenced in a process that it's
painting that has nothing to do with
those images that they see in a flat
screen so there's a level of sensitivity
and Sensibility that is being removed
from this entire process and my wish was
to make this ductility back as an
element that help us to understand the
world to experience the world and to
create work that have this knowledge in
it without excluding technology as the
like ultimate painter would say oh no
bad evil computers
um
and so I'm really agreeing with Adina
here it's about getting the tools and to
master it and to as well even if I'm a
terrible coder I learn how to code just
so I can understand the systems but I'm
really bad at that
um
it's to give me the intellectual as well
ability to know how the system works how
it is and this goes as well to the
discussion about the biases it's about
ethics it's about distribution of power
when you know then you can be creative
and you can do things with that to
wherever you take it that's my take on
it
I think that's actually a very good
place
to end this part of the program
um it has been a real Joy
to speak with the three of you and to
have you here with us today
you know we talked about the promise
of technology and it's really it just
came up with a question here
what does a promise mean what do we
expect what do we hope for what we wish
for what do we anticipate what could we
do with it I really like the way all
three of you were talking so much about
us taking taking that in our hands
as actors and trying to be active
citizens active participants active
learners
and to make sure that we're also as
aware as we can be
for the decisions which are being made
and helping to influence those
so thank you very much all of you for
coming over for coming up and for all of
you for coming here this evening let's
give them a great Round of Applause
before we finish
foreign
so tomorrow
we will be hosting another rethinking
living conversation
same place different time at 17 30 5 30
tomorrow evening we'll be talking
rethinking cities and I hope that many
of you will consider coming us not just
on a Friday night but on a Saturday
night
so thank you for choosing for being here
and thank you for enjoying the Berlin
science week
all right everybody
[Applause]